this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks it's great to be here with you
and look forward to opportunity to
sharing a little bit of of what I do and
Maria said that to me as walked in it'll
be interesting to see what you do and I
get that a lot
because this is kind of a kind of a
specialized area in terms of Workforce
development's within agriculture but
this component I wanted to get to share
some of the some of the trends that are
happening in agriculture that are really
making the workforce the number one
issue if you go out in the industry and
I don't care what industry whether it's
dairy or fruit and vegetable or you will
if you ask producers they will indicate
labor as the biggest challenge they face
today barnum and so this really has the
potential to be transformative and it
already is transforming our industry so
I think it's important even those of us
that are you know working in the lab
more working in more applied their basic
research I think you need to understand
what is happening in terms of labor and
the potential that does have to to
change the industries we work with so a
couple of topics that we'll get into
today are the labor market and the
historic tightness that we are
experiencing demographic change
particularly in Mexico and some what
guatemalan other Caribbean countries
which a lot of people aren't aware of
but our long-term structural changes
that no policy is going to change and
then last we'll have a look at some of
the technology that is already having an
impact on agriculture which I think in
the next ten years is going to have a
tremendous impact on agriculture and the
workforce okay I will use the mouse to
click forward let's look at US
unemployment rate and what we have here
in this graph is from 2008 up through
2018 so this is unemployment in the
United States and you can see there's a
high point about 2009 and that comes
just a few years after the Great
Recession many of you might remember
that the housing crisis others might
call it and what that led to was a
historic slowdown and the highest
unemployment rate the
we had in this country since the Great
Depression many of us remember that and
but you can see that trend since that
time a steady steady steady decline over
a really long time which is quite
amazing but there's even a couple of
headlines that wanted to pull up and
show you this is from last year from The
Wall Street Journal jobless rate Falls
to lowest in nearly 50 years as
employers ramp up hiring and then of
course there's more to that story but
still the the raw number the raw fact is
that the unemployment rate is very very
low in this country so I'm looking at
this number I want you to start thinking
about what impact does this have on the
foreign workforce but that was from May
of last year I wanted to update that a
little bit so just from October last
year again Wall Street Journal The
Economist wonder how low the US
unemployment rate can go and that's
still quite a discussion and we'll get
into the details too much there but
interest rates haven't going up much
inflation hasn't gone up much and so
that's that's a question that economists
are actively debating right now is how
low can I don't believe me go and just
for the economists that are in the room
and elsewhere full unemployment is
usually considered around five percent
right five four or five percent we don't
ever get much below that because people
are always changing jobs a small
percentage of people who are moving from
one job to another and one other
interesting little fact in the United
States right now there are more job
openings than there are unemployed
people so think about that one for a
minute even if we could match the skills
of all the people who are currently
unemployed with all the job openings
that are available we simply wouldn't
have enough people to fill the openings
so so again what impact might that have
on farms so that's one of the firsts one
of the first factors extremely low
extremely low unemployment and farms
very often are the on the the lower tier
of desirability I'll put it that way in
terms of employment people tend to want
to go to other industries let's look at
another factor
having an impact and that is
demographics in the United States so
this graph is of u.s. population loss in
non-metro counties what I'm looking up
we have Metro counties on there as well
but you can see the dotted zero line
which so this is population law so
anything above that would be growth
anything below that would be actual loss
of population so Metro counties would be
the more urban counties around cities
and the suburbs around that non Metro
then would be the rural counties where
most of the farms are so straight out
population you could see we had some
slow growth and that the Green Line is
the non Metro some slow growth back
there in the 90s and 95 and but now
we've actually dropped below so rural
counties are now losing population and
this doesn't illustrate it quite as well
as the next slide I'm going to show you
which is a county-by-county breakdown
and what you're looking at on the left
hand side that map is again all the
counties broken down that is from the
period from 2002 to 2008 so right up to
the great recession that we talked about
and the the colors that you're looking
at anything that is that light tan or
the little bit darker brown that's
actually growth the light tan is is a
slow growth about less than 5% the blue
is lost it is decline in population and
then the the black and gray areas that's
the that's the metro part so that's sort
of the cities are and the counties
surrounding that so what we're paying
attention to is the blue the counties
that have lost population you can look
the 2000 to 2008 period on the left you
can see where the blue is but you see
still quite a lot of tan and even some
darker brown in rural counties the map
on the right hand side is 2010 to 2016
so the period we're in you know up until
now look at what happened with those
blue counties
rural America rural counties are
emptying out population is declining
there's fewer and fewer people total
living in those counties now let's think
about that for a moment who stays is
that the young energetic people looking
for a job
no it's the people that are more
established that you know maybe you're
closer to retirement they tend to stay
the young energetic people that are
looking for jobs and to advance their
careers they're migrating to the urban
centers into those suburban counties so
we've got this dramatic shift of
population literally declining and late
if you look if you can see closely
enough there you can look at New York in
particular where there was quite a bit
of that light brown and that earlier
period up until 2008 and then after 2010
it's blue everywhere those northern tier
counties now are declining and this long
term has implications for where forms
will get their labor force much of new
light New England for sure and even look
down you know through the the Midwest a
bit you can see that there used to be
there's light tan and even some brown
counties in the Midwest heavy
agricultural areas but now there's a lot
of blue that prevails throughout the
whole eastern half the United States
it's growing everywhere but especially
the eastern United States
another important population group in
agriculture in the last 20 years
actually more than that but it's really
been profound especially in the
Northeast in the last 20 years where
people who were immigrants from other
countries primarily Mexico and in many
cases were working in an unauthorized
status that's just the reality if you
worked with farms over that period of
time there were a lot of people or they
might have had documentation and in most
cases the farms were looking at that
documentation but in many cases that
documentation was not was not all it was
not totally authentic and many of the
folks working there were unauthorized
there's been a big change and some of
that as you might imagine you hear the
news stories about a border wall and
increased enforcement at the border that
actually started all the way back in the
George Bush administration up through
the Obama administration and then
dramatically increase in the Trump
administration as you've seen in the
news as this had an impact on
immigration yes it has
it has dramatically increased the cost
for people to migrate across the border
versus what it was 20 years or so ago
and if you talk with farms there used to
be people showing up in New York and I'm
talking about in the 90s and early 2000s
we're showing up and looking for work
farmers would go out and you know if
they needed someone they could ask one
of their existing employees and quickly
there'd be applicants showing up for
work that pipeline doesn't in many cases
it's gone dry now you can add farmers or
ass workers if there's an additional
person available and sometimes the
workers will simply come back and say
there's no one available and that's
that's how dramatically a population has
changed the Pew Research Center which is
one of our best data sources for the
information about the unauthorized
workforce without this report a few
years ago and this is the change of
population of the unauthorized
population in the United States from
2007 to 2016 you can see California
going down by over half a million people
and you can see New York right behind it
at 300,000 so huge decreases and you can
see this on the farm so it's changed the
structure of the workforce
changed how how farms fine people and
hire people
I get the question a lot so how does Pew
come up with that number and I've
provided you with the link to go to it
and watch the video that they share but
in a very brief nutshell they take
census data from both the US and Mexico
to get the overall population of
immigrants in the country and they have
very good data then on permanent
residents and refugees here in the
country so if you take the overall
number of immigrants minus the lawful
immigrants that's how you can come up
with a number of unauthorized area
simplistic way I put it they have
statisticians and demographers that make
a lot of adjustments and corrections it
goes way beyond me to understand how
they do that but at that website they
explain it in a lot of detail but the
fact is we have far fewer on our
unauthorized workers in the country at
this point which leads us to why we
already talked about the border wall a
little bit and so that's that's part of
the situation but there's some other
more fundamental changes taking place
that have to do with demographics this
next chart is of Mexico so it's a
fertility rate in Mexico starting out
back in 1960 and rolling up through the
early 2010's
up close to the present time back then
1960 you can see and the way fertility
rate is measured it's simply the number
of births per woman in the country
so back then we were almost seven births
per woman in the country and that held
up until about 1970 and then you start
to see that dramatic decline all the way
down to just over were a little over 2.1
2.2 births for a woman in the country do
you buy know where we are in the United
States on that measure
it's about 1.7 1.8 we're below
replacement value so the u.s. population
as it is today doesn't replace itself we
we need immigration just to maintain the
population that we that we presently
have and I'll show you a world map a
little later that that shows some of
that in more detail
so let's study this a little bit so I
mentioned to you before that in the
1990s and 2000s there was this large
number of people coming into the country
taking jobs in agriculture now and most
of those folks what mostly was men there
were a few women but for the most part
it's men and they were in their early
20s right looking for jobs looking for
opportunities so if it was 1990 when
were they born 1970 right or thereabout
somewhere up over 10 more years 2000
they were born you know 1980 when the
popular the the birth rate was still
fairly high but going down look forward
to today in 2020 they were born in what
2000 when the birth rate was way lower
so that change is carrying through now
we're not seeing as many young people
that are coming to that working age now
because the change in the birth rate
let's take another look at some of the
some similar information really so this
is called a population pyramid and what
I've got is 1980 on the left hand side
2017 on the rights this is Mexico and
the way you read this is that the blue
is men the red is women and this is like
slices of a layer cake so the bottom
slice there on left hand side for 1980
there's children zero to four years of
age and then five to nine and then ten
to fourteen and five-year increments all
the way up in this case to 80 plus so
you can you can kind of sector out the
population and so what do we have lots
and lots of children right does that fit
with a previous slide of course it does
high birth rate we had lots of children
that were that were in the population
well let's flash
was that 37 years you can see how the
population changed and you can see how
that pyramid went from this really wide
expansion with lots of children to kind
of the narrowing down of that population
pyramid what does that start to make us
think about the economy and about the
population it's more stable isn't it at
least the population I won't comment on
the economy yet but the population of
Mexico has largely stabilized it is more
kind of self-sustaining well let's let's
look at the economics of that so this is
gross domestic product per capita this
is all in current US dollars
for Mexico so we've got Mexico that has
stabilized in population and this goes
from 1960 up to about 2017 I believe and
you can see that Mexico has grown from
less than $1,000 per capita GDP up to
almost 11,000 at one point is down a
little bit here in the last couple of
years but it's it's heading back up now
that's pretty dramatic growth over that
period of time isn't it you see it was
kind of a slow growth to begin and then
kind of a dramatic growth I won't
comment any further than to say that
NAFTA was right there in 1994 that's
what went into place and so there is
there's a lot of hypotheses about the
impact that NAFTA had on population
flows and also what is apparently the
part of its impact on GDP in Mexico but
you know you can draw some some of those
conclusions for yourself Mexico is still
referred to as a developing country so
the World Bank identifies which
countries are developed in which they
are which are developing countries so
the United States and Europe or the
classic developed countries developed
developing countries tend to be
countries that are that are poor have
less of a developed developed economy
and don't have as many jobs and that
sort of thing but Mexico is right at the
top as one of the most developed of the
developing countries so it's almost
ready to move out of that developing
classification into a developed country
because it's the highest developed in
the developing world so that's so things
are changing so let's think for a moment
about the drive then to find jobs so
20 years ago Mexico wasn't as developed
population wasn't or the population
wasn't stabilized and the income GDP per
capita wasn't as high and so there was a
lot of push to come out of Mexico and
come to the United States and find a job
opportunity there's less of that it's
still a big difference in terms of wages
you still can earn five to seven times
as much by working in the United States
as what you can in Mexico and I talked
about Mexico a lot because Mexico makes
up about 70% of the of the immigrant
workforce in agriculture in the United
States so it's still by far the biggest
player
many of you may have run into Guatemalan
workers in New York because that's
another important population group so
now that we're kind of oriented to those
population pyramids I wanted to also
show you
Guatemala zoo Guatemala has the same
dynamic going on it just hasn't hasn't
slowed nearly as fast and there's the
United States you could see United
States is very very stable if anything
declining a little bit in terms of
population size and there's the world
snapshot so to orient you here the blue
areas are those countries that are in
population decline Europe Japan no real
surprises there and then the red areas
and the brighter red they are like in
Africa is where we have the growth areas
of the world so as we think ahead to
other to our country and other countries
that are that are developed where might
the future workforce be coming from if
we are bringing in workers from other
countries potentially Africa are parts
of Asia oops wrong direction
okay I'm going to be brief so as I
mentioned the we do bring people in
where we do bring workers in from other
parts of the world the United States
that's called the h-2a program so this
is the fully legal federal program to
bring in temporary guest workers you
have to be an employer working in the US
and agriculture have to have at least
full-time work 35 hours a week and it
has to be temporary seasonal ten months
or less typically it is rather expensive
all transportation costs housing must be
paid by the employer and the for this
year the new wage rate minimum wage for
is called the a where and it's going to
be $14 for 29 cents an hour so it's
relatively high compared to two other
farm labor and it's got some pretty high
barriers one of the challenges with H to
a larger farms and ones that have been
in it for quite a while that ones that
have more administrative overhead and
can deal with the paperwork aspect of it
are better able to manage H to a smaller
farms that you know you don't have as
much office staff to manage the
administrative part of it it's much
harder to be involved in the h-2a
process and I just want to be brief with
a couple of these things this is just
kind of an overview but the federal
government is always very helpful and
they give us some visual aid so just to
simplify things for you I wanted to
share the visual aid that farms have to
go through in order to get a worker and
once you've done all this you're about
halfway there because you've just gotten
through the Department of Labor part now
you have to go to the immigration part
of it
so all that notwithstanding in the last
ten years this is to thousands of 2018
this is growth of the h-2a program in
new york and this is the number of
positions that were certified approved
to work in new york we were in over
4,000 back in 2008 kind of stable there
for a while but in recent years has been
pretty dramatic growth again as as other
populations that we used to draw from
are disappearing
there's increased reliance on h-2a and
farmers will say hto is expensive it's
difficult but at least it's reliable I
can get people and some of the other
sources of labour I just can't get
people anymore
this is overall United States just a
little bit different look at it this is
97 to 2017 the blue line is the number
of visas granted the gray line is
positioned certified I won't get into
that but the blue line is more exactly
the number of people that come in it's a
little technical what the difference is
there so I won't spend time on it but
the story here is dramatic growth
overall not just New York even faster
really in some other parts of the
country you may have heard some news
about at the federal level there is a
proposed revision to h-2a and more it's
called the farm workforce modernization
act this is that work in this field for
the last 20 years that there have been
we've come really close to legislation
in the past and it always got to shut
down one way or another there's been no
change to federal immigration law since
1986 that's an awfully long time for a
program like this so this program is
intended to change things for
agriculture
it would create a pathway to permanent
resident status for people who have been
working in agriculture already they
would have h-2a reforms that would
simplify that process and also would
create an opportunity for year-round
employers like dairy and some other
year-round employers to have people here
on three-year visas three years at a
time
the trade-off would be mandatory
e-verify but I won't get into that in
detail a little bit more a closer
picture of what HOA looks like in New
York so we've had a tradition for a long
time in New York of Jamaican workers in
especially the Apple industry and
certainly the onion industry in fact
last year one of the workers in the
Apple industry celebrated 50 years of
coming back on h-2a contracts to work in
the United States I thought was just
amazing we Mexico is also another very
large contributor more in the fruit and
vegetable lot in
the in the grape industry as well so I
wanted to share Jamaica real quickly and
you can see the same idea
Jamaica 1980 in Jamaica in 2017 that
pyramids starting to pinch in at the
bottom so you don't have an expanding
workforce in Jamaica even though those
folks have been coming from Jamaica very
loyal workforce coming back year after
year to year they're not being replaced
very quickly by younger workers
so that brings us after looking at some
of that data to the challenge for
agriculture labor is increasingly scarce
but farmers need good employees in order
to operate successful businesses and I
like to share this with farms that even
with u.s. immigration policy reform
which we might in fact get this year who
knows labor will remain scarce even if
we get that reform in place it's still
gonna be hard to find people going
forward so my message always with
farmers is that you've got to be on top
of your game in terms of recruiting and
keeping good people so let's look at
some of the drivers of change and they
here we're gonna try to use some of the
technology and cross your fingers that
it works out okay but a lot of you would
be familiar with an apple orchard there
this is a trellis system and I know that
there are production reasons for having
the child system better light access and
so forth but the labor situation is a
major reason that we've moved more to
trellises and hopefully everyone can see
that and hopefully it will play this is
an extension produce video the point I
like to make about that is the the
transition to the fruiting wall allows
much more efficient use of labor so some
of those platforms that people use they
have workers at different levels as you
go along the trellis you can harvest
really quickly and not have to go back
and forth not have to use ladders and
all those sort of things so that's
that's part of it but the other part
that people many people aren't familiar
with I want to share in this video so
setting up orchards in that way is
foreshadowing robots we're thinking
about how can robots be put into place
and in Europe they've been working on it
very quickly Washington State is working
on it very quickly too there's strong
potential to reduce labor needs but the
capital investment of course is very
high but as we continue to have the
labor shortages I think we're gonna see
this technology continue to advance
[Music]
so that's kind of a vacuum system we
have people at Cornell right now that
are working on more of a finger tight
system to harvest and in fact there's
another seminar going on right now that
talks about that
wish I could have been at that
[Laughter]
so another look at some of the robots
that are out there in operation so I'll
start in the top right corner with a
little red and white robot that machine
is you see it does have a solar panel on
top I'm not sure if it's completely
solar operated but it is suckering
grapevines so I'm cutting off the shoots
there on the bottom the little guy on
the end yellow on the lower right-hand
side I'm not exactly sure what what that
one is doing but he's in an orchard of
some type as well the one in the middle
I'm not sure if you can see but that is
a solar panel on top of it this is
operating in California I believe and it
goes through that lettuce field that
it's in it can identify with electronic
eyes identify weeds from lettuce and it
will weed and destroy the take out the
weeds in that field and the upper
left-hand corner just kind of a
different concept there this is a
tractor mounted machine also in a
lettuce field doing the same job so it's
got robotic technology that's able to
scan the rows of lettuce and take out
the weeds and then the lower-left-hand
so yeah I want to give you the idea that
there's there's two trains of thought
going on the robotics one is smaller
scale or we might deploy a lot of small
robots to do the work that that humans
used to do there's also a larger scale
so that tractor on the left but then you
see the combine harvesting corn in the
grain cart next to it that it's dumping
the court into there's only one Operator
there there's an operator in the combine
the tractor is entirely empty there's no
operator in that it is able to go over
to the the field where there's a truck
waiting and unload into that truck
without any operator in it so we just
took a two-person job and made in one
person job so lots of change is
happening in all different ways though
taking place
for those of you familiar with the dairy
industry robotics have existed for like
30-some years primarily in Europe where
they've had a labor shortage before we
did that the last slide if you if you
look at that's the scan of a freestyle
type barn that little red shed is
actually where the robot is it's inside
that shed the cows go there on their own
voluntarily to be milked when they
choose to and so that's this is a
picture of the milk or itself it's not
just the milking process this is a
feeding unit that is mixing feed itself
to feed the cows similarly this is a
calf feeding unit that's fully robotic
so dairy lends itself well to robotics
because a lot of things are stationary
we don't have to go out in a field as
much this is actually a carousel type
milking parlor it goes around cows climb
up on it and it goes around in a circle
right now those operate with typically
four or five melkor's workers around
that carousel in different stations
slowly they're being replaced not too
far from here there's one with a robotic
arm that's replaced some of the workers
there eventually this will be fully
automated there will only be robots
operating in that large carousel and
it'll eliminate the the need for people
in the milking parlor I wanted to show
you these are not directly agricultural
applications but when you see these
videos you're gonna realize how far
these capabilities have come and how
quickly they're coming about so robots
are maybe a little more mobile than what
you thought
we've all done that right no this is
fully navigating a stop
again think about the application
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I love to see how people react to that
video because you know there's sympathy
there's emotion when the robot remember
that's not a person that's just a bucket
of bolts straight it looks like a person
but it's it's not and so what does that
mean I don't know what that means but
it's just interesting to see audience
always always react that way here's
another one looking at some dexterity
issues
[Music]
okay so as I mentioned bargaining and
and the Netherlands has been a real
leader here and I just wanted to quote
one of the people on the robotics
projects over there and the AG and food
industry is you see robots is very
promising
robots enable us to make up for the
shortage in the workforce it is also
possible to achieve higher production
through box and he goes on to say that
robots will be doing all the menial
repetitive work and 10 to 20 years from
now so you know I've talked a lot about
jobs being replaced and I don't want to
come across as if I'm happy about that
you know we've all got our own opinions
on that the reality in agriculture is
that we've seen that that workforce is
shrinking and there's nothing we can do
to stop it and largely that's a global
statement not just the United States
state so we need to find ways to replace
some of that labor because we simply
won't have it no matter what we do so
the impact on jobs Congress just solved
from the Society for Human Resource
Management an article about Congress
examining the future of work issues and
this is about robotics they're looking
at you know so it's not just agriculture
of course so you can see in the lower
middle picture there if you've been to
McDonald's lately you might have ordered
from one of these kiosks and that's
directly to replace the the cashiers the
waitstaff and the only thing it was in
the news here in December this is a
truck 20 tons of butter that made a
fully automated cross-country trip from
California to Philadelphia in December
though there was an operator in there
but the operator didn't do anything he
just watched as that truck drove itself
across the country so the trucking
industry has a huge deficit of employees
right now they really are struggling to
get Drucker's so they're really pushing
hard on long-haul trucks to replace
humans
so yeah what impact is that going to
have on jobs in the future that's
something we all need to we need to
figure out you know I'm trying to think
this thing through from the standpoint
of agriculture and the fact that we do
have declining number of people my
outlook on on on jobs in agriculture
future workforce in agriculture is that
yes a lot of that heavy manual and
repetitive labor will be largely
automated and people have different
opinions on that you know a lot of that
frontline farm labor can be very hard
hot out in the weather and that sort of
thing some people will say good
we don't want humans doing that type of
work anymore it's better to automate
that other people will say I don't know
not so fast you know that's kind of a
stepping stone frontline job for a lot
of people too to really advance
themselves so that's you know a lot of
opinions on that I think people will
maintain and operate machines make
decisions on information and allow
specialized tasks there's a lot of
things that I think will be a long time
before they can be automated and I think
the remaining jobs in agriculture will
be these high skill high wage jobs that
will remain taking care of that
technology making these decisions I
think our challenge in agriculture is
going to be that we need to recruit
people from all walks of life so for all
intents and purposes the the farm kids
pipeline that's already gone there just
aren't farm kids like there were in
previous generations there very few a
number and nowhere near able to fill all
the jobs that there will be in
agriculture in the future we need be
recruiting people from urban areas from
suburban areas from all walks of life
need to be finding people that are
interested in working with food we need
to be recruiting as a food industry not
just farms but as a whole food industry
and we need to be finding people that
like plants that like animals that don't
want to be stuck in a cubicle that's a
kind of a paradigm shift in how we are
attracting people into our industry I
think we need to build pathways for
those folks as well so build awareness
of careers in the broader food industry
you know much of the current population
doesn't take agriculture seriously or
think at all about agriculture as a
viable career path I suspect that many
of you are you know kind of maybe didn't
come from farms but how
discovered agriculture of discovered
plants have discovered you know animals
are interested and want to pursue a
career there and that's all we need to
grow and expand this interest in where
food comes from in some ways it's
threatening to agriculture but in other
ways we need to turn that around and
make it a positive in order to attract
people and and bring people in I think
we need to foster associate degree and
technical programs and that sort of
thing and one of the things I work on a
lot is professionalizing the workforce
agricultural work used to be very
informal we need to be more formal about
that regulations are in part driving
that but if we want employers farm
employers to be attractive people need
to understand what it's like to work
there what the expectations are and be
very clear and good feedback what's my
career path and all those sort of things
and so that's one of the things that we
work on a lot with farm employers so I'm
gonna wrap it up at that point I've
heard a lot of information at you but I
hope you might have a few questions -
300 thousand that you had up there in
terms of unauthorized workforce and I'm
trying to maybe this is chicken in the
egg right so on the one hand you know
agriculture as in group technology group
labor efficiency since forever right
right so though there's a decreasing in
farm labor part of that's because
there's less of a demand for farm labor
than there used to be as opposed to
there's less people coming to work in
the farms it's not wasted what which is
driving so the question is so we saw the
chart that had the decline in the
unauthorized population in New York of
300,000 people or that ten year period
and the question is so is that because
of less available jobs or less people to
take those jobs and I don't know if we
can separate that that's something we'd
have to spend some more time thinking
about I think
either one ends up being tied pretty
closely to the other yeah and we are
seeing it I use a dairy example because
we have a lot of good data about dairy
labor over a period of time yes you can
clearly see in the data and we measure
cows per worker farms are becoming much
more efficient steadily year after year
and the number of cows that can be cared
for by one worker so it would be
interesting to look at that and the
fruit vegetable industries to it see how
efficiencies have changed there you
started right but that's an impetus to
even invest more and rd4 right for labor
efficiencies for reducing the demand for
labor right if it's part of that is
accompanied by I don't know if you'd
call it a trend and you know
technological change that has increased
over time then I don't I just heard me
would like to sort of it maybe it's
80/20 maybe it's 50/50 I have no idea
yeah it certainly has more I mean I
think the way you started with the issue
of these population dynamics or look
like right that it's him they're not
there they're not going to be there is a
better cause we know for sure that labor
supply has gone down and I think that
the farm employers have responded to
that by adopting more and more
technology yeah a vast majority of
farmers say in New York and South the
country actually pretty small scale and
you know it seems to me all these
examples you shiver fascinating but it
seems like you're pretty capital
intensive so I'm not sure how how should
a small farmer review this that's coming
along cuz I agree with you yeah it's
gonna go that way but how is that going
to impact our farm communities and rural
communities so the question was a vast
majority of farms still are smaller
farms that may not be as dependent on a
large workforce and so what should what
should a smaller farm think about some
of these trends I think there's a
possibility that creates some
opportunity if you have a small farm and
just because you're small doesn't
necessarily mean that you're gonna have
a market and then a market that's going
to be profitable enough for you to
actually make a living on so that's a
whole other
economic question there but if you're
able to do that and if you're able to
capitalize on the fact that you are
small and that you're able to rely on
family labor and you can even turn that
into a marketing piece for you then I
think that potentially opens up some
opportunities challenge and this is
something that I'm hearing more and more
with some of the small farms especially
as there's been this great increase in
the interests in agriculture and more
urban areas are closer to the city
so sometimes folks get on to some small
farms and they have a great idea and
they feel really energetic about it and
then they kind of burn out because
they're not making any money at it and
they struggle with that pretty quickly
so I think I think there's some
opportunities potentially there but I
think that's even those small farms that
this is they get to even somewhat larger
scale they start to need employees so
they'll start experiencing that very
quickly there's so replacement how you
I'm assuming that you're basically well
that's an interesting yeah so the
question was synthetic biologicals to
root to create you know meat free
burgers and and things like that yeah I
don't claim to keep up on that real
closely but just a quick thought on that
from from a workforce standpoint is that
that's a more industrial type of
manufacturing which would be able to be
highly mechanized versus farms which is
much more pastoral and that's what makes
it difficult to mechanize much of
Agriculture's because you have whether
you have field conditions you have all
these things that need humans with
products that are more manufactured like
that you can roboticize that you can
have more of a so that might be a
potential advantage for those natural
food
statements is that they would be highly
mechanized that's my gist initial
thoughts for really an eye-opening
presentation thanks so much this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at Cornell edu